hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm Katrina Alicia
Katrina Alicia this is a two and a half
to three months go have in the making
right here hopefully it's worth it she
is part of the fan theory TV YouTube
channels you cover Doctor Who yes and
watch who with Paula Deming yes Paula
who's been on this channel so I felt it
was only fair to stop the jealousy the
behind the scenes arguments ever
happening which is so many fine I'll
bring Katrina you watch game with guns
yes absolutely I'm all cut up right now
there's only one episode left
how are you overall liking it let's save
that we're gonna watch three minutes a
game of thrones cast being disappointed
by season eight hey I've seen a so many
articles of this going around some
subscribers sent this to us I'm curious
to see what they have to say let's do it
have you shot your final scenes yeah and
are you
I hate to tell you that unfortunately
person is God because I mean a number of
you I'm sure have read the books and I
read the books and I reason to expect oh
I've got a journey here in fact if I'm
honest I thought oh I'm really bored
this season I'm gonna have more to do
I'm going to get my teeth into something
I'm really looking forward to did you
did you say anything so I think I did
ask and give an argument why poor person
should stay but the other day I mean you
know down David you know they've worked
out what they want to do and you know if
you've planned your book that the butler
did it and then you read an internet
someone has figured out that the butler
did it
and you suddenly change in midstream and
it was the chambermaid who did it then
you screw up the book if you get these
that's foreshadowing early on and you've
got these little clues you planted now
that dead ends and you have to introduce
other clues and you're retconning it's a
manual
lavoy they expected a jon snow has
always been the hero the one who's in
the savior but it just didn't seem right
to us for this for this moment how do
you feel about the way that it is there
are no better writers in television than
Dan Weiss and David Benioff better than
I could have imagined and you people are
in for even try there's like what am i
publicist tell me to say wrote down for
me to make sure I memorize and answer
with what the PR tell me so what have
you been thinking of this season it's so
rushed right now it's so rushed and I
just don't understand why they're
rushing through it it could have given
us a few more episodes if they're
planning on putting the money into
spin-offs yeah I'm doing that why
couldn't they have like given us eight
to ten episodes in this season I've
pretty much had this one feeling the
entire season which is all these choices
have been fine I think the choices are
fine everything on a technical scale in
terms of directing and your option is
all beautiful it's some of the best
that's ever been on TV but it's really
being hampered by less episodes there's
less emotional impact for pretty much
there's no time everything yeah there's
less breathing room less build-up and
it's like we need it was like double the
episodes are like four to five more
episodes just to really earn stuff just
like really take in some of these deaths
it feels like a checklist season you
know so just like get it out of the way
building up for the night and then it's
just like I'm sure a lot of this is just
so out of context you know you're just
watching this like montage cut together
someone you know went and pulled stuff
yeah to make it look worse than it
actually is but there are certain
elements here where like
yes it could have just been some of that
British sarcasm all you Brits have it yo
soy de your time Jones snow by me oh
really quick I did read something very
recently I was reading from something
from the actor who plays varies and
spoilers if you haven't been caught of a
game of Thrones he dies at the very
beginning so we're just seeing him with
hair by the way I have not seen him with
hair he was a video he had hair that we
watched he was in it he's with bran when
they're talk no further back that's him
holy crap he grows hair hey that's good
to know
now he has a chance for diversity out
there I found this quote from him this
is the only thing I read which is not
included in this video it might just be
some like reporter interview I was
bummed out to not have any reaction to
Aiden Gillan's Littlefinger dying if he
was my nemesis that's been my feeling
the last couple seasons that my
character became more peripheral that
they concentrated on others more that's
fine it's the nature of a multi
character show it was kind of
frustrating as a whole it's been
overwhelmingly positive really but I
suppose the last couple seasons weren't
my favorite not enthusiastic about this
last couple season
I don't feel like we were you know
pining for spectacle Game of Thrones has
been fine for every season to have their
second-to-last episode be the spectacle
episode the one battle of the bastards
for example like those and now I'm like
you know I it's really currency watching
this guest Oh out of everyone here who
would seem like the most struggling to
have a hard time just getting on board
with it it did seem like Peter Dinklage
yeah cuz they showed two moments a few
moments with him he seems disappointed
in even while Emilia Clarke - she in the
beginning her face like she didn't hide
it very well I can't imagine how this
show will actually end on a widow he
puts
I'm trying to think like who I think is
gonna end up on the throne we've all had
these theories they don't matter going
crazy here two years being like what if
it's this what if it's that what if it's
this you know we've all just there's
been a million theories out there and
they've literally just shoved those all
and prophecies - yeah I I find it funny
how this show is since since the
beginning of this season especially it's
like they'll have a set up for something
and then as Game of Thrones fans were
like okay but what's gonna happen well
this is it what's gonna happen what's
gonna and then what ends up happening is
exactly what they set up and it's like
the predictable route like the last
episode during the credits we were
talking or like oh yeah she's probably
gonna go mad at Queen here and even
though we knew that we she was gonna go
mad Queen in this episode and probably
kill all the innocent people it was
still like I feel quite hurt even though
it's like we saw it coming it's a mixed
reaction you watch her like when her
brother like dies and doesn't even bat
an eye you know yeah she's always had
that mad Queen in her like she always
has but we've always been rooting for
her because we've always been on her
side if she's gotta you know break free
from all of these men and this and that
and so we've always been on her side
even though she has always had that
craziness to her and now but men should
be in charge Katrina I hope you realize
that slam dunk that I'm so glad to bring
you on here for the first video where we
can definitely get it mixed response to
how we respond I don't want to bring you
on when we're like ah you know
everyone's gonna like you here we're
gonna bring you off for one where it's a
it's a controversial topic definitely
controversial I know so many people
right now who or who feel so differently
I know people who love some people think
this is the best season something is
absolute war see yeah friends who are
literally like shut up everybody this is
the best blah blah blah for all of these
reasons
I have my other friends who are just
like this sucks because of all of these
reasons I'm just like well I feel like
some people care more about execution
than just the choice you know like
that's what I mean I'm totally cool but
the choices they make with the actor for
Gendry when he was just like that stuff
that I want I even heard Nicola whatever
his name is the guy plays Jamie complain
about how they handled his character arc
I read some article where he was being
interviewed and he was bringing up my
exact issue with his arc of how he
sleeps and Brienne that same episode
some inner conflict comes out so just
some tail yeah in the crap in the same
episode he burped he leaves Brienne and
then in the next episode he dies with
Cersei if you count that total amount of
screen time in both those episodes it's
like 30 minutes of screen time I'm like
all that yeah and to have your on
Greyjoy what was that whole like I don't
know what you're on Greyjoy had some
like big he like has this whole like I
killed Jamie don't care about him get a
moment I lucked out I had no idea what
your sounds like every through through
size really lucked out that we are on a
similar page here cuz I have friends who
are not in the same page as me oh well
guys man are you excited for the season
finale of Game of Thrones
I'm sure the cast members of the show
are as well you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell follow Katrina on social media but
as well as on a fan Theory tea Tube
channel and keep a lookout for the real
rejects reaction to the last episode of
the courage